Let's go next to our collar, from the
361 area code, who's calling today, from 361
oil this bill con in from Texas assisting.
Yes, it is Bill from Texas, yeah.
Alright, so I just wanted to ask.
So, it's pretty clear that Bernie is not gonna
be winning this
nomination but is it overwhelmingly likely
that you necessarily get to majority?
Not that I'm
advocating any fantastic mention, but I was
just curious, is it gonna get an outright
majority, 'cause
I use it.
I Tribble he is.
And remember Bernie said whoever has a plurality
should get the nomination, so I
don't think it'll make a difference by and
will certainly have a plurality.
I think there's a good chance
he ends up with a majority as well.
By the time it's all said and done.
Yeah, I know Bernie said that he wouldn't
contest, it basically, but I was just thinking
that if biting
somehow failed to get the majority, I didn't
know there'll be a bad sign for the general
election of
that happened.
I don't believe so, and again, burn.
Like I said, Bernie said it, that debate whoever
has a plurality should be the nominee.
So I don't think it's gonna be an issue are
other than that, at
this point, with the corona virus and I guess
stuff going on with oil prices.
Do you have any basic
assessment of...
Are we at a great risk for another recession?
You think?
I think the answer is probably, but I can't
control it and therefore I'm not gonna try
to get...
So
basically at my age, my plan financially remains
unchanged which is, If this is the great destruction
if this is the beginning of the end of the
United States, it doesn't really matter where
I put my money
I'm gonna lose it all.
So under the assumption that this is not the
end, and that in the past, every downturn
has been
followed by a recovery.
My plan is to continue just investing in index
funds mostly equities with
some bonds as appropriate for my age sticking
to my allocation, and just keep accumulating
shares
with the idea that over the long term, I'm
gonna do okay.
And then that way I don't have to worry so
much about, is it or isn't it a recession?
I'm not trying to time anything or any of
those things, that's
my approach.
Alright, Ethan that...
I guess my last question is just about Michigan,
in particular, I noticed that if
you compare bundled at this point to Hillel
at this equivalent point is, is actually lower.
And she
didn't even end up winning that.
So what do you...
I don't know if you have a "sasanian particular
03/13/20 Page 10 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
and...
Or Democrat, odds and picking it back for
their calm.
We're gonna assess that all in a lot of detail
once we get closer to the general.
But no, no particular
thoughts on that.
Bill, thank you for the call, I really do
appreciate it.